if you had to describe the overall tone
of season four what are a few adjectives
that come to mind oh I think it's I
think it's hot hot hot hot for who I
think it's hot for several of our
characters I want to talk to you about
the female orgasm it's pretty surreal to
me as a fan of the show to be sitting
here on the set season for mono it's
real to me how are you feeling oh it's
wonderful I mean the fans were so you
know incredible Mike and I have both
been on shows that have been canceled
and people don't care so to have this
show get as much love as we got and to
have the fans really rally behind us and
then have pop come and save us it was
really wonderful okay so I want to talk
about that whole journey obviously not
very fun hearing the news that a beloved
show that so many fans like myself just
loved and cherish so dearly gets
canceled you then begin this process of
can we get the band back together what
do we do talk me through that well you
know this is really a credit to Sony you
know they they said we're gonna keep
fighting because normally we have to go
to the studio and say please keep
fighting for us and they didn't have to
do that they were really already saying
we are gonna fight we're gonna try to
find a new home for the show there have
been interest over the course of the
first three seasons and so they were
able to circle back with some people and
make this happen so if credit to Sony
had credit to pop I want to know where
were you or how did you find out that
we're giving this a go season four is
happening it has been sort of like on
you know it was like months and months
and months for us on life support so we
felt like it's today the day that either
it's done or the eyes open you know it
really felt like that so it was months
of maybe
and one day we just got the call and
Mike and I just cried and hugged and
we're so happy we could tell more
stories about this family we love them
can you show me the face you made when
you found it was just like you know just
I'm just stunned just stunned just
stunned what anything like that happens
in Hollywood I think you just sort of
take a moment and say this is a special
rare thing yeah absolutely you know it's
it's common that sometimes a show will
get saved but there's a lot of layers as
you know and it's hard to get the whole
set back or the whole crew back or the
whole cast back what did you manage to
get back and what did you not manage to
get back everyone's mad Wow actors get
busy no they you know they were on
contract I think for the period of time
with it all worked out within the the
time where we had them and they were so
eager to all come back so they made it
they worked around us and everybody was
just really keen to be back so okay
thrilled we're thrilled I want to know
about the set yeah so we're we're on the
same watch yes but in a different sound
state we're in a different sound stage
this one is bigger and nicer oh no it's
a beautiful set it's a little bit
quieter but this is our set from the
first three seasons so so you didn't
have to say we got to rebuild the couch
we got it so this is all the oh geez oh
geez oh here so it's really like nothing
has changed is changed do me a favor
mommy you stay out of my love life I
made you a profile on tinder
says lonely Catholic nurse seeks big
strong man to fill the hole in her life
we might want to reward them making the
jump from streaming to traditional cable
what are the changes or the hurdles that
you guys have had to adapt to well
really it's just going back to
traditional multicam so commercials and
act breaks and shorter time so at the
beginning we were like oh we don't want
less yeah we're gonna make you know five
to six minutes we're gonna miss that
time but then after the first episode I
remember I was sitting with Justine and
reading we were like if we don't miss it
we told a complete story yeah so it is
it a little punchy or a little it's just
a little snappier yeah and we just kind
of barrel through and yeah it's fun it's
been great I have to say it's you know
we were like you know we'll miss the
time but I don't miss the time okay yeah
you know the other thing about cable is
that it's appointment viewing so I'm
really excited that I can say to my
family or my sister and my husband you
know Tuesday nights we're watching one
day at a time on pop yeah no ifs ands or
buts about it well I also really love
that it's once a week it lets them
breathe a little bit
it lets each episode sort of stand on
phone and the you know we really
interact with our fans we love our fans
on Twitter and Instagram so I say yeah
you know so to be able to talk to them
about each episode individually it's
more what Norman did and it's really
more how you sort of break into culture
a little bit more so you know I remember
when we were streaming it would be 6:00
a.m. on Friday morning after we dropped
in people early I watched the whole
thing I've finished it boy it feels so
we're all really excited about the
opportunity to just let each episode to
sit yeah talk about it and how it
impacted the community and and kind of
go from there so that's exciting as a
writer you now have the benefit I
imagine of being able to write as you go
as opposed to let's write a whole bunch
let's Bank a whole bunch of episodes and
then give it to the world yeah so how
does that impact your writing process
well we are still really um you know
and so we break everything pretty early
because Mike and I have we have soap
that the amount of stories we have for
this family yeah Emily so we've broken
the whole the whole fourth season
already it does allow us to be a little
bit more topical in terms of what's
going to be happening this year what are
things that we can talk about that
before we would have had to wait six
months or a year before those saw by
balls and so now we can be a little bit
closer to when things are actually
happening in the world well I know you
guys are always paying attention to
those hard to talk about topics but you
kind of digest them and make them
interesting informative entertaining
what are you sinking your teeth into in
season four well this year we're really
talking about the census and how
important it is especially for
communities of color to be a part of the
census it really affects how much money
goes into your districts and so
traditionally Atlantic's people under
report and because of fear you do not
have to say that you're a citizen or not
and it's really really important that
people do it so we really tackle the
census in the first episode and then we
talk a little bit more about sexual
health and aging and romance and
friendship and you know we really kind
of continue on the journey with where
these characters are at this moment in
time in their lives if you had to
describe the overall tone of season four
what are a few adjectives that come to
mind oh I think it's I think it's hot
hot hot hot for who I think it's hot for
several of our characters really yeah
you're up in a romance pack we're upping
it okay yeah the kids are getting older
okay everyone wants to learn more get a
little romantic this year someone opens
the door that they shouldn't you walked
in on our
he walked in under so in season four
what are some of the bigger plot points
or things we can look forward to well
alex has a girlfriend this year Oh papi
thaw and things are moving real fast
really yeah how's Penelope feeling about
that it's something there's some there's
some things that happen behind the
bedroom door behind the bedroom door
well let's just say there's a pregnancy
test found and it's positive and that's
all I'm gonna say
what is the message behind that
storyline well it's about talking to
your kids about their sexual health I
think that a lot of households don't I
think it's also talking about safe sex
we've done it with she's a nurse so this
is all health-related for Elena and said
sit his back sit his back goodness and
things are going great until they don't
you guys what are they fighting about
maybe maybe a young lady gets in their
way so it's about honesty about
communicating with your partner
especially at a very young level and you
know how betrayal doesn't have to just
mean actually doing something physical
of course it can be very emotional
absolutely yes
what about my girl Penelope no she's
getting any love this to know he gets
love this season yes what was behind
that decision well after last season we
really wanted her to feel like she was
okay on her own and we did that and we
do feel like this character is a woman
who is very self-sufficient but just
because you're self-sufficient and a
feminist doesn't mean you stole
she deserves companionship just as much
as anyone else and so she kind of comes
to terms with that and the first episode
realizes wait I can still be like a
badass and a feminist it's still I love
in my life there you go
I love being a little more strong women
who don't need a partner to define them
anyway I have a date so a huge part of
the show that we love is the really
incredible guest stars yes who is your
dream you want to kind of make a little
plea to the camera
well lumen well obviously he knows he
knows we text about it he's very busy
yes of course of course yes so what's
holding he's directing a movie he has
another little movie called in the
heights coming out he's a busy fella 164
today no we'll figure it out Oh anything
you can do anything I could do anything
he's amazing uh who else I would love
Selena Gomez would be amazing Oh perfect
Camila caballo would be amazing yes do a
little singing she cook with our boy I
can also do anything hmm
this show does so much for next
representation and I know it means a lot
to you
to give back so what is it that you guys
are doing on the show this season to
kind of foster that goodness and that
giving back well really showing me the
very fact that it's about a lot mixed
family the royal family at the core that
loves each other that works hard that
really hopefully usurps all of the
stereotypes that are out there about our
community this is a loving warm funny
family just like any family that lives
next door and to be able to normalize
that and show that without all of the
stereotypes that I think our community
is so tired of seeing our mere existence
is sort of a political statement our
costume designer and actually our props
people are they're sourcing local Latin
X artists for posters Wow they're
sourcing latinus artists for paintings
they're sourcing for t-shirt design for
fashion design our costume designer is
is getting a bunch of Latin X costume
designers and and and fashion designers
and so we're trying to be very
thoughtful in the way that we're
representing the community in every
aspect and a network like pop to say we
want one day at a time a show that
prioritizes putting a spotlight on the
Latin X community what kind of message
does that send it says that were
important and that we're worth listening
to and worth representing and worth
marketing to that's you know spend a lot
of money we're one in four at the box
office opening we think you want to be
speaking to us
[Music]